good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight there are a lot of
things going on around the world at the
moment but we thought we would begin
tonight with a report from your own
country just to give you something a
little different from what you've been
watching every moment of every day for
the past three weeks
on your screen are pictures from
brooklyn new york these are people
waiting in line at a food bank the queue
stretches for blocks it's what we used
to call a breadline
most these people are not homeless or
not addicted to drugs some of them have
jobs they just can't afford enough food
very few living americans have ever seen
anything like this it's been nearly a
hundred years since the united states
experienced widespread food shortages
that's long enough that most of us have
forgotten what it means and here's what
it means if you want to make a society
volatile not just angry and divided
which is where we are now but
revolutionary and explosive then you
threaten the food supply
more governments have fallen to rising
food prices than to any other cause by
far
hungry people are dangerous
the bite administration doesn't seem to
notice this is happening or acknowledge
it
like all neoliberals they treat
unchanging truths about anything as
heresy they censor them and shut them
down
they live in an entirely ideological
world that they created they believe
reality conforms to their theories not
the other way around and why wouldn't
they think that if you can change your
sex just by wishing it so you can
probably eliminate inflation simply by
pretending it doesn't exist when you're
god there are no limits
the problem is they're not god they're
not even very capable economists
more than a decade of reckless fiscal
policies have devalued the us dollar to
the point that middle-class people can
barely survive in the united states
now the suffering of regular americans
doesn't have the thrilling imminence of
say war footage from ukraine but it's
real and it matters and here's what it
looks like
in number terms
this year according to new estimate
rising inflation will cost the average
american family three thousand five
hundred dollars in extra post tax income
now that might be bearable if you make
250 grand a year though you would notice
it but if you make 35 000 a year that's
a disaster you will radically change the
way you live your standard of living
will plummet
and that's exactly what millions of
americans are facing right now it's not
a talking point it's real
americans for tax reform found that
between november of 2020 and november of
2021 quote the bottom 20 of earners
spent 309 more on food 761 dollars more
on energy 476 more on shelter 390 more
on other commodities and 224 dollars
more on other services
and those are the numbers from november
they've risen dramatically since then
and they're continuing to rise
nationally meat poultry fish eggs up 13
in san francisco a dozen eggs is almost
five dollars orange juice in miami is
over four bucks so is a chicken breast
in boston a pound of ground beef
hamburger in la six dollars and 34 cents
a pound of bacon in new york city 728.
in chicago last year green grapes cost
200 2.50 cents a pound another four
dollars the price of chicken wings and
the catskills went from eight dollars to
20 bucks order something else
if you try to drink a pint of guinness
in california yesterday to celebrate st
patrick's day it cost you eight dollars
and 55 cents for a pint of beer
prices of everything are rising far
faster than wages are a lot faster and
that means that in very real terms the
most real people are becoming poorer
and not just people who buy things
consumers but also people who sell them
retailers this is a disaster for small
business watch
for a cold hard lesson on inflation step
into the refrigerator where carina
gudino wallink stores the food supplies
she just bought for her pop-up food
stamp business in phoenix arizona so
usually it would be the boneless would
be about a dollar a pound
right now it's 184 a pound this cheese
used to be nine dollars right now it's
on it's like 14.56 and that makes it
hard for someone like you to run your
business correct it makes it
unbelievably
difficult for us to predict any pricing
i can't even say i'm going to charge you
a certain price right now because in
three days it's probably bound to change
you know and it's never for the better
did you catch that at the end price is
changing every three days it's like
vymar or zimbabwe
that is not the picture of a stable
economy and it's not just food that's
moving fast in the city of baltimore the
cost of electricity has risen 18 percent
in a single year that does not happen
with utilities but it just did
in philadelphia the average utility bill
rose from 477 dollars a month to 651
dollars a month
according to national association of
home builders building material prices
increased almost 21
year-over-year overall lumber prices
alone have added almost 19 000
to the price of a home in the past six
months
that's one of the reasons housing prices
are so high and then of course there's
gasoline in los angeles it now costs
about a hundred and eighty dollars to
fill a chevy suburban one tank of gas
180 bucks
nationally gas is up nearly 40 percent
and here's what that looks like
these prices are eye popping here at the
chevron it's 7.29 a gallon for a small
car with a 12 gallon tank it would cost
you 87
to fill it all the way up of course we
know this is the top end of the spectrum
here in california it's the most
expensive state the average price for a
gallon here is 5.67
but we all know that nationally these
prices are through the roof the average
cost nationwide now is 4.33 cents a
gallon that's up 63 cents in just a
week's time in fact right now the
average cost is climbed above four
dollars a gallon in a staggering 38
states
rising gas prices makes people desperate
you wouldn't know that from watching
television because most people who bring
you the news don't know what the price
of gas is and a lot of them don't care
because they don't drive themselves
but the rest of the country cares very
deeply what the price of gases and in
some places the problem is so bad gas
prices are so expensive that thieves
have taken to drilling holes in gas
tanks to steal it
with the national average at 4.33 cents
a gallon a troubling new trend is on the
rise gas theft
crimes of opportunity now happening
across the country criminals are
targeting unattended vehicles for gas
but they're not going in through here
instead they're drilling holes from
underneath your car
and draining your tank and once the tank
is drilled it can't be fixed getting a
new one could cost drivers more than a
thousand dollars contrary to what you
may have learned from sandy cortez's
tick tock feed the internal combustion
engine is not a sin it's not the basis
of a moral crisis it is a miracle upon
which all civilization rests your amazon
package arrives because of gasoline so
does your uber eats you can fly to see
your relatives across the country
because of gasoline so when the price of
gasoline rises
everyone is affected no matter who they
voted for and no matter whether they
notice it directly or not
here's how people in the state of texas
are reacting to the rising gas prices
gas has reached an all-time record high
and here in dallas texas it's four
dollars and 19 cents a gallon let's go
talk to texans and see what they think
about these prices they're high real
high it's absurd ridiculous you're
spending more money to go do
to make money so
[Music]
it's hard but it's outrageous you know
it's kind of outrageous i'm gonna like
to they've been high for a long time now
they're too hot
will the capital of ukraine fall to the
russians we certainly hope not americans
care about that
how high will gas get americans care
about that even more they care deeply
because it affects their lives so
dramatically and yet the coverage of
this is not proportionate you almost
never hear anybody asked what do you
think of the price of gas but if you
leave the tv studios of new york los
angeles and washington you will find
people really do care
every product in this country with some
exceptions but not that many is
delivered thanks to gasoline
and that means with rising gas prices
all products become more expensive the
cheapest washing machine you can buy it
is say best buy in south carolina right
now 450 bucks furniture and bedding
across the country is 17 more expensive
than it was a year ago
12 months ago a 28 cubic foot samsung
stainless steel fridge was selling for
1700 bucks at home depot it's now 2 000
and so on for everything and
particularly for vehicles the average
price of a used car is up more than 30
percent nationally it's up 35 in
massachusetts and tennessee it's up 38
in florida and maryland it's up 40 or
more in louisiana new york montana and
north dakota
that means the average cost of a used
car in the state of montana is now more
than 42 thousand dollars for a used car
some with high mileage
by comparison last march the average
used toyota sold for 20 thousand dollars
the average used toyota now goes for 28
000.
these are real numbers with real effects
to restate the standard of living
of americans who for almost 100 years
have enjoyed the world's highest
standard of living in any big country is
plummeting
so what's the administration doing to
fix this what are they doing to help
well of course that depends upon whether
or not you're ukrainian if you are
they can help you if you're not our
transportation secretary recommends you
take the bus
you do have a lot of capacity in public
transit and that's something that you
know i hope becomes a a means of choice
we need to make sure that there is less
pressure on family budgets from
transportation which is often the second
biggest budget item after housing itself
one of the tools that we have in our
toolkit to do that is to make sure
there's access to excellent public
transportation
take the bus yeah homeless
schizophrenics have been doing it for
generations why shouldn't you
you can't afford to drive that's the
transportation secretary so maybe the
first question would be what are you
going to do about gas prices pal
the roads are falling apart maybe you
could fix that no
one of the tools in our tool kit is you
can ride the bus with the crazy people
and you'll like it
but that's not their only plan to fight
inflation their other plan
blame others
now that we live in an america where
there's a lot more concentration in
certain industries look at the oil
industry look at
meat industry look at groceries
generally
that what's happened is these companies
have said
you know we'll pass along costs but
while we're at it and everyone's talking
about rising costs let's just add an
extra big dollop of cost increases to
expand our profits
you just heard from someone who's a
sitting united states senator
whose total reservoir of knowledge about
the world is smaller than the sink in
your powder room
this is someone who knows literally
nothing about how anything works the
meat industry what would that be senator
warren she has no idea what she's
talking about she has no interest in
learning why the dollar is less
valuable than it was 10 years ago and
she has no interest whatsoever in
improving your life
so the question once again is how long
can this continue
it's one thing to pretend that boys can
compete in girls sports and that's
totally natural it's always the way it's
been that may be offensive to people but
when they can't afford to buy groceries
boy you are really teetering on the edge
of something awful they should wake up
soon hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else